how was your corona experience oh wow
that's so weird how um
corona yeah how did you get corona how
long did it last tell me give me the
skinny on it
i had i had it bad too like i listened
like up until i got it i was like i've
had a cold before i'll be
fine so what it's the flu what's the big
deal bro i was down two weeks
two weeks like i was sick for
like you hear what happened was what
happened was
um i i got
one day i started having a little bit of
a cough no big deal
and my my girlfriend came over that like
she came over that night okay no big
deal she comes over we go out we hang
out
we go to bed the next morning i woke up
and i was i was done like i mean i
literally in the middle of the night i
woke up and i went and checked the
thermostat because i thought
you know it's a new apartment yeah where
are you getting the sweats and stuff
yeah i started sweating and what i
thought happened was
i thought the thermostat might have like
might have raised itself up because you
know how they'll do that sometimes
i don't know it's just a brand new
apartment maybe it automatically does it
i go and i check and it said it was like
72. i was like that's crazy it's not
working
i hit it all the way down to like 68 got
back in bed next morning when i wake up
i'm like
i look up and and i go yes jess and
she's like
what what's up and i go so hot i said
are you hot and she goes i'm
freezing oh no and my whole body was
achy
and i thought how could i be achill feel
like this like i didn't work out hard or
anything
how am i so [ __ ] up listen i couldn't
get out of bed
i mean i like crawled out of bed and i
was like i'm so i'm in so much pain
i was sweating and then i laid back down
like baby i was like
because we were supposed to go to church
and i go baby i don't
i don't think church matt cox goes to
church
i know he's going to oh [ __ ] repent that
sounds like a movie
repair that doesn't sound like a movie
goes to church listen my girlfriend
church and i want to go to church
because i want
to you know we can do that together and
she likes that
and if it's important to her then it's
important to me god bless jesus christ
jesus christ oh my god my lord and
savior
hey pour me some of that bailey's in
here ooh we got [ __ ] bailey's on the
podcast today
[ __ ] so anyway yeah so what you're uh
you're all [ __ ] up when you wake up
and go the doctor are you no i don't
know we i laid in bed for like an hour
or so and she was like what's wrong with
you how do you feel like what are your
and so as we slowly started talking
she was like you've got all the symptoms
of cobalt she was everything who your
girl said
yeah and we looked it up and we read
them off and i had a bunch of them
and then look i laid in bed we laid in
bed all day
slept all day and then she left the next
either that night or the next morning
and then yeah and then the next day i
couldn't get out of bed the next day
and then i'd say on oh no no you know
what happened
that monday right then that that next
day it was sunday so then on monday
morning i went straight got tested
bam it said code so i was like [ __ ] how
long did you have to wait in line for
like 45 minutes maybe an hour god damn
it was it just touching it was a line
like a driver no everybody says that
this wasn't this was
this was in bradenton i had to get out i
just stand in line
i'm hacking and coughing everybody else
is there to do it for work
like they're all like oh i gotta get
just tested for work and i'm sitting
there
i'm sitting there hot and sw hot and
sweating one minute and then the next
minute i'm like
[ __ ] it's cold i should have brought a
jacket you know and it was perfect it
was a great day was like 70 degrees
and guys people are looking at me and
then this one woman's looking at me and
she's like
how do you feel i was like i feel
horrible and she she'd already had it
and she came back because she had
blisters or something on the bottoms of
her feet
[ __ ] oh she was telling me she said oh
yeah some people are getting like their
toes are turning red and
she's there's all kinds of weird new
symptoms
anyway but she was like yeah you're
probably you might have a hard time and
i was like i i run like four miles a day
i'm gonna be good i'll be over this in a
couple days so when they when they
tested you possibly long
way wrong about that what did the uh
nurses there
say to you once you were positive have
you been tested
yes i have been i'm negative my wife
actually just recently got tested too
she's negative
but they had like a van that did they
have did you go stand in line or did you
i had to go wait in line did you see
that with the guys the gloves were like
hazmat no okay listen so this thing i
wait in line
after i get in line the first thing you
have to do is you go to like these
military like these
police guys right like but there's like
the military and they you show them your
id
you get a kit then you go then this guy
authenticates the kit then you walk up
this the stairs like i was
[ __ ] too forever so i go up there
they had two plexi
like whatever glass or plexiglass
windows
with these people that have like like
you know like gloves like
they're standing behind it and they have
gloves and they're like okay
take the kit okay they take the kit they
do the whole thing they
okay they do the whole thing and then
they drop it in the box and they say
okay you'll be
someone will test somebody will well
you'll be contacted or emailed or
in the next you know within 20 minutes
and by the time i got back to my car
uh i'd already gotten like 10 minutes
later five minutes later
i was so messed up i walked right by my
car and walked
all the way to the wrong parking lot god
damn
got there and was like where'd i park
where did i park and i was like you
idiot you parked right next to the line
i'm like oh my god turned around came
all the way back and
my phone went off i checked out and boom
it said you know positive
when when you were positive did the
nurses tell you anything like what you
should do
i got a phone call from somebody with a
hillsborough county cdc
like or whatever you want to call it
whatever the local the county cdc type
thing
that's the county down there well okay
well it was mandated well it wasn't the
cdc but
whatever it was it was like the county
cdc type situation
and she called and she's like okay how
do you feel how this i was like oh this
and this and this and
she just told me look you know all she
was like
you know take zinc take
you know vitamin d vitamin c sleep as
much as you can lay in bed drink lots of
water
you know all the stuff you're supposed
to say yeah mom would say yeah
eat some chicken noodle soup yeah you'll
be all right so what'd you do you're
healthy you shook it off in like what 48
hours
that's like so like two weeks later
here's the thing you know how everybody
talks about like oh i keep you can't br
first of all
i couldn't taste anything and that had
already that had already happened i
didn't realize it
until i started look looking back like
and thinking
i told you guys about getting like a
flat tire right no
anyway i had gotten a flat tire and i
actually
my car's so cheap they don't even have a
you don't even have a spare tire
so and this was during the tropical
storm thing so anyway when i got out of
the car and i had to take the big
platform thing in the back to try and
remove the tire that isn't actually
there it's actually like a big can of
fix a flat
um i got it it got all wet so then my
car smelled like mildew
jess had said your car smells like
mildew do you smell that and i went
no and she goes you don't smell that and
i was like no
and that was during the day remember it
wasn't until the next day that i
realized i was sick so it was already
happening i couldn't smell anything
i realized that the next day because i
went when i went home like i went to
i took a shower after the thing and i
sprayed
cologne on i was like i can't smell this
at all
like usually you it's overwhelming right
nothing so i started realizing whoa i
got some problems
so then i was sick for a while like i
was in bed for two or three days
then i was so bored look by the way by
this point jess got sick
i was gonna ask that she is sick too
yeah she got sick because
we couldn't have been more close that
night you know [ __ ] so did she actually
get tested or she just like chalk it up
to the game
i got covered too because i'm next to
them oh no she went got checked she got
checked
and she works at a like a dairy plant so
she can't she got
she got tested and then thug yeah so she
sounds gnarly
so she got tested and they won't let you
she obviously she can't work there yeah
so couldn't go to school came and stayed
with me for a couple days
and then by like day day two or
something like that like the second or
third day she goes listen i can't lay in
bed anymore
she goes i'm gonna i'm gonna go fishing
and i went i
um i'll go and she was like yeah
sick sweating tired achy
she goes fishing what kind of fishing
does she do fishing
i don't know anything about fishing she
doesn't tell you where she goes fishing
and she sends me pictures of fish
and houses that's all you know fish what
kind of fish
i don't know you got a picture on your
phone i got a bunch of pictures what
kind of fish he's catching
i don't know what kind of fish they are
you i mean if you show me the picture i
could probably figure it out
it's a goddamn angler i'm a goddamn fish
man you see those tridents over there in
the corner
you ever watched deckhands nobody
watches decades are you talking
um i got wait i got bad pictures in here
she fishing for grouper is she getting
tilapia in the lakes
oh i gotta okay she's fishing for
trouser snake
yeah she is
what the hell is that jones
it's a grouper that's not a i don't know
what the [ __ ] it's not a fish that looks
like a [ __ ]
he almost said that's not a fish that
looks like a bass does look or bass
that's a [ __ ] bass bro she's fishing
in bass fishing she's
fishing in the lakes yeah wow i don't
know
i guess land oh you live in lando lakes
that makes sense
no i don't we don't shoot this is this
is down by um
uh bradenton um there's tons of little
play you know out there it's it's couch
she's fishing for trouser trout
so she goes off she goes fishing right
you know what she did the next day
well actually it was the same day she
went that she didn't fish the first day
the first day she got home and her dad
said hey
if she was gonna go fishing he's like
well if you got the day off he said i
got all this stuff to
fix the brakes on my car if you want to
fix them
and she was like yeah i'll fix them so
she spent all day replacing her dad's
brakes
ah damn she can replace brakes listen i
told you when my
my alternator went bad and i was like
look this [ __ ] is rugged bro
that ain't getting those hands dirty
look at those perfectly manicured
fingernails that's horrible when my
when my my car stopped she gets out with
the jumper cables
and gives puts them on hers and gives
them to me and i looked at them and i
went
um what do i do so i was like which
one's positive and she looked at me she
was oh jesus god oh my god she's giving
me the
boom she put them on she just let it run
let's charge the battery i'm like well
should we drive started let's go and
she's like let it charge
we don't know what's wrong you got to
get home i said no let's go to the
garage across the street i'm just going
to park it there so they can fix it
and she goes it's your alternator shoes
it's three bolts i'll fix it this
weekend
and i went i can't i can't and i
remember thinking i can't tell anybody
this story
but it's the first thing you can't do
but
anyway i dropped it off and she's like
you know i'll just go i can
it's not a big deal i was like i i
cannot let you
there's there's no way so yeah she's uh
she's a gangster so she fixed her dad's
breaks to one day the next day she went
fishing next day she came back she was
over in three days i was down for two
weeks
oh my gosh i couldn't it was so bad
remember i told you i built that thing
the wall yeah yeah yeah
in your studio in my studio so i built
this two walls but i built i bought all
the
wood for one wow when i went to home
depot
got the wood came back unloaded the wood
i had to lay down and sleep
go to sleep for like an hour then the
next day i cut the wood like i could get
up cut the wood
and it wasn't that i couldn't breathe it
was that
i was immediately felt like i just
gotten off of
like i just run like five miles like i
was just like at one point you finally
stand up and you're just like
i haven't done anything i've been active
for barely active
for five minutes yeah and i'm like
but i didn't feel like i couldn't
breathe do you need nausea do you throw
up at all
i haven't thrown up since 1992. really
yeah and that was only because i was
poisoned you were poisoned i was
poisoned i smoked a cigar
and i didn't spit out the saliva
no thank you which i apparently you have
to do like i was talking to my cousin
nate and i said
bro i don't have any vices and i was
like i need a vice i don't drink i don't
smoke i don't do anything i need a vice
and he goes what about cigars how about
mortgage fraud
that wasn't that was that was later so
he i smoke a cigar throughout the night
as we were playing putt-putt golf and by
the 18th hole i was puking my [ __ ]
guts out
puked for like you're probably inhaling
it not just that i'm i'm swallowing all
the saliva he can't yeah he can't do all
that no he kept
spitting or he would put it out yeah and
i was and he knew what he was doing he
knew he was getting me sick
yeah to beat you in golf no just in
general just to let me know
you don't you don't need to be doing
this it's a bad idea
yeah you don't need a mice no these need
snipped you just bite the end off bro
there's a little tingle swisher sweets
just bite the end off yeah
like a blunt wrap so that was it i was
down so two [ __ ] weeks two weeks and
then i then for the next week
i couldn't work out i just started
working out a couple days ago mm-hmm
literally
that [ __ ] [ __ ] you up first day i did
five i did
five mo uh five minutes next day i did
nine today
yesterday i did 15 minutes i'm trying to
build up on the elliptical
yeah i'm trying to build up to 30
minutes i'm still tired
so i'm exhausted well i'm glad you
survived
i gained yeah thank god did you think
you were going to get you were going to
die
pounds i gained like eight pounds 175
right now did it ever cross your mind
you're like i'm gonna die no there was
only there was only one day when i was
laying there in bed like after a week or
so and i remember thinking
bro if you don't start feeling better
you may end up in the hospital
like this this isn't normal you're going
on like day 10
day 11. you're still sweating you still
i'm still sweating i'm still having you
know i'm still have a fever
going up and down i thought nah bro you
you you can't go this long
it's you're gonna end up you could
[ __ ] die next thing you know i'm
sitting there i'm not a gangster anymore
i'm like you're an old man
your girlfriend's already okay you know
what the hell it was horrible
that guy ben i used to do the videos
with he got [ __ ] he was in the
hospital
with like pneumonia and [ __ ] he survived
if he survived anybody can [ __ ]
[Laughter]
survive